was soll das denn muss los oder meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren der
heutige tag ist ein tag an dem wir alle
aufatmen können unsere lieblings
ratgeberserie hilft mir hat in den
letzten wochen eine schwere zeit
durchgemacht zu beginn der hilft mir
upload auf youtube haben die folgen
teilweise noch 34 millionen klicks
gemacht in den letzten wochen dann nur
noch 300.000 500.000 aber damit ist
jetzt schluss denn die definitiv beste
und sinnvollste ratgeberserie
deutschlands hat den sprung in die top 4
der youtube trends wieder geschafft und
ist wieder voll am start ist und soll
ich mit solchen abwegigen um sind wie
das familienmitglieder oder der eigene
freund 80 sind nein die heutige folge
trägt den ganz klassischen titel ein
bisschen bi schadet nie und ich hörte es
kurz scheiße labern und übergebe an den
besten fernsehsender deutschlands
bühne frei für rtl2 ok alles klar
ich glaube nicht hat sich auch nach der
letzten folge der nazi folge also der
mit dem nazi bruder mich noch irgendwas
stoppen kann das hier sieht der
mannschaft aber auch schon recht
sachlich aus scheint so als würde sich
da eine szene an bahn in der zwei männer
eine junge frau körperlich überwältigen
um
er hat eben schon gesagt das ist
natürlich mal wieder eine sehr ehrenloge
unlock also wir sind auf gutem kurs
also ich weiss es darstellen soll ist
also darstellen
die frau würde mir abgepasst ist schon
so ein bisschen dunkel und männer beugen
sie irgendwie missbrauchen oder so aber
wie wir es von unserer lieblings
erkennen ist dass hier wieder mal
absolut beschissen die schauspieler dass
er danach aus als würden sich elfjährige
auf dem schulhof in her schubsen als das
mit irgendwas passiert
gut also an der stelle ich wieder an dem
punkt angelangt dass das was in der
folge passiert mit mir persönlich
überhaupt nichts zu tun hat ich habe
keine ahnung von gewaltverbrechen
besonders nicht von gewaltverbrechen die
über frauen
aber mir scheint so als hätten diese den
jungen männer ihre ziele nicht ganz klar
definiert hat fall haben wir gesagt auf
die frage hin was wollt ihr
wir wollen punkten punkt und jetzt
kommen sie aber mal aus was denn jetzt
schon so ein bisschen so eine scheiße
macht dann lasst doch zumindest die
leute sind auf einstellen was passiert
und wechseln ich zwischendrin die strafe
also das denn wieso muss man es mir so
schwer machen rtl2 bitte wenn du sie mal
von rtl2 sie könnt ihr mich nicht
bisschen langsam anfangen lassen bis sie
für mich als jemand dass diese folge
anschaut und dass sie mit kommentiert
über das unterhalten ist es das
schlimmste wenn die folge einfach schon
so ihren los losgeht wenn ich ein auto
habe und das fahren will dann gebe ich
nicht kalt vollgas ist es nicht gut wenn
ich joggen will dann springt dich nicht
am anfang los man muss die ganze sache
bis hinauf werden okay und nicht so voll
in die fresse mit so der absolut ersten
scheiße dies geht aus dem planeten dass
hier was wir nämlich gerade sehen ist
ganz kurz ein lob von meiner seite somit
das verabscheuungswürdige was ich
persönlich finde dass man machen kann
ich kenne da tatsächlich fälle aus
meinem umfeld meinem bekanntenkreis wo
mädels so was passiert ist und egal
real talk männer die so was machen alter
direkt kastration deren margendruck
befüllen mit einem halben kilo blumen
sie dann ein jahr in der zelle sperren
in der dauerschleife rtl2 läuft
wo ist das ehren losada rtl2 was es mit
dem hit folgen passiert wenn man einfach
zuschauen konnte sich darüber lustig
machen könnte warum kommt jetzt hätten
wir folgen bei dem man sich aktiv
schmutzig wenn man sie schaut könnt ihr
nicht irgendwie noch mal jemanden messen
lassen
bitte
[Musik]
ok mich beschleicht der verdacht dass
diese story von dieser folge ich leben
2001 ist okay ich weiß wir sind hier bei
einer produktion die die genial ist eine
handlungsstränge in der weltweiten
filmbranche hat aber ich sag mal mein
call ist dass die blonde jetzt lesbisch
oder bisexuell mit der frau wird die sie
gerettet macht auf jeden fall sind wir
haben gerade einen glasklaren ganz
brutalen raub gesehen
dank an der stelle auch noch mal an die
erinnerung was ich gerade gesehen habe
habe ich innerhalb der drei sekunden
schon fast wieder vergessen zum glück
für das junge opfer kamen die passanten
noch zu hilfe
das junge opfer sollte schnellstmöglich
zur polizei gehen und eine strafanzeige
erstatten und natürlich auch jetzt an
diesem zeitpunkt definitiv in erwägung
ziehen mit der person die sie gerettet
hat eine beziehung anzufangen und
bisexuell zu werden ich muss jetzt auch
wieder zur arbeit ok als er muss zur
arbeit das heißt das hier ist der
wohnung also auch jeder 800 jeder kann
seine wohnung einrichten er möchte aber
diese kisten dann links dann auf der
rechten seite so eine offene wand möbel
und im hintergrund hängen einfach
fucking schwerter an der wand nicht ein
schwert mehrere schwerter über der
wasserkiste perfekt wenn ihr mal gäste
hat und die haben durst sagt sebastian
wolk nicht oder wasser das ist ja in den
vorratsraum direkt unter den drei
schwerter natürlich darf auch im
hintergrund ein bild von einem indianer
häuptling nicht fehlen ist jetzt seit
neuestem dank der neuen
steuergesetzgebung in deutschland auch
verpflichtend wenn nicht ein bild vom
indianerhäuptling und drei schwerter in
der eigenen wohnung hat kann auf jeden
fall den platz kommen
wenn jetzt nicht gerettet ich bin echt
froh darum aber mainz nicht sie hat
irgendetwas verdient eine kleinigkeit
als geschenk jetzt nach fähigkeiten
blumenstrauß oder sowas
die kommen zusammen leute ja die kommen
zusammen
ich habe gemerkt der wind kommt so aus
leicht dieser richtung und weht so auf
sie zu auf meinem bildschirm schon einen
blumenstrauß weil die wird zum tiefen
eindruck auf mich gemacht und ich glaube
blumenstrauß werde ich das falsch jetzt
geht es darum was sie quasi ihre
retterin gibt um sich für die rettung zu
bedanken
ich glaube sie gibt sich selbst wenn ihr
wissen was ich mal der nächste tag fia
will sich bei ihrer retterin bedanken
okay okay okay okay okay okay eins nach
dem anderen
also für alle für die das gerade eben
schon eine seltsame hinrichtung war die
welt soll mal richtig raus geschäft
sie macht die tür auf in boxhandschuhen
klinger wohl eben diese menschen gibt
die verfolger auftauchen ich habe schon
ein paar wohnungen von einer menschen
gesehen da war noch nie in schwer
dritten mal mit boxhandschuhen die
haustür aufgemacht und indianer heute
habe ich bisher auch nicht also wieder
gesehen
okay da haben wir links eine klimmzug
stange das ist jetzt nicht bös gemeint
deutsche das einfach aus einer
realistischen perspektive die klar und
nicht dass sie da ernsthaft klimmzüge
trainiert an alle mädels zuschauer
selbst kraft tritt machen mit klimmzügen
probiert haben schreibt mir gerne die
kommentare ob ihr denken dass diese
kommt zustande von hier aktiv genutzt
wird
ich habe da meine zweifel
es ist wieder so schlecht leute es so
faktisch schlecht achtet man darauf wie
sie die wand schlägt niemand deren zahl
und boxt schlägt so eine wand im boxer
oder zumindest ein teil boxer sowie ich
kennengelernt habe was ich den sport
gemacht habe klingt nicht so sondern so
sagen kann man die hand so raus dabei
seien sie über die box ist bei jedem
wetter morgens wenn sie nervt schau dir
diese in eine richtung alter das ist ja
geisteskrank ist es ein fucking es ist
ein antiquitätenladen das ist eine
wohnung
da passt einfach nicht zusammen
es sieht aus als hätte jemand beim blind
bestellt und einfach so eine wohnung
eingerichtet
ich bin nicht dazu da dass geschenke
herzform die geht voran
das mag auch irgendwie nicht so sind
oder wenn man verschenkt zum
lebkuchenherz vollkommen brennendem so
weit ich freue mich auf dem jahrmarkt
oder so man eigentlich lebkuchenherz
zukauf und die andere so geil
mann ich wollte schon immer ein
lebkuchenherz haben sowieso realistisch
ist so ein scheiß würde und mich
irgendwann falsch versteht damit meine
ich nicht dass zwei frauen sich küssen
dass das schlimme ist sondern die eine
wurde gerade missbraucht vor nicht allzu
langer zeit was macht die andere perfekt
da haben wir eine chillige
missbrauchsopfer der drücke ich noch
erstmal wieder überraschend und
ungefragten kurs auf oder menschen
abstoßend an der stelle kommt heute das
war der erste teil dieser folge der
zweite kommt direkt morgen damit er
nicht lange warten müsst haut rein
bleibt stabil und checkt ein für euch
vorgeschlagen das video ab meine sehr
verehrten haben